Life Hack: a gun-free America in 5 easy steps.
For a gun-free America, the first thing you'll
need is two-thirds of Congress.
So elect a minimum of 67 Senators and 290
Representatives who are on your side.
Then, have them vote to propose an amendment
to the Constitution
which repeals Second Amendment gun rights
for all Americans.
Then convince the legislators of 38 states
to ratify that amendment.
Congratulations, the Second Amendment is now
history!
At this point you've done nothing to decrease
gun violence.
All you've done is remove the barrier for
Congress to legally act.
You need to enact "common sense"
gun reform.
You can try to do what Australia did and...ban
all guns?
That's not at all what they did,
but whatever, fuck it.
Go big or go home, right?
Get that law passed by Congress and signed
by the president.
Great!
The law is passed and guns are now illegal.
The only thing left to do is...
Enforce the law.
Guns don't just disappear because you passed
a law.
You need to confiscate some 350 million guns
scattered among over 330 Million Americans.
Sure, you can try a buy-back program like
Australia,
but like Australia that will still leave behind
anywhere from 60 percent to 80 percent of
privately owned firearms.
The rest of them you have to take.
You'll need the police, the FBI, the ATF,
the National Guard—
all known for their nuanced approach to potentially
dangerous situations—
to go door-to-door, through 3.8 million square
miles of this country and take them, by force,
from thousands, if not, millions of well-armed
individuals.
Many of whom would rather start a civil war
than acquiesce.
So inevitably gun violence, which is currently
at a historic low, will skyrocket.
But that is how you get a gun-free America
in five easy steps.